now if you have a thyroid problem this video
is going to be very very important to you
the first thing you need to know is that most
thyroid conditions both hyper and hypo involved
auto immune thyroid disease in other words
ninety percent of hypothyroid conditions
are an autoimmune condition called hashimoto's
and seventy percent of the hyperthyroid conditions
are graves disease which is another autoimmune
disease and so now let's talk about the
relationship between gluten and the thyroid
because gluten creates celiac which is an
inflammatory condition which destroys a little
villi the little roots of the intestine which
then allow the proteins to invade the lymphatic
system and the immune system and now you have
these antibodies that attack this protein and so
gluten is a protein it's the protein of certain
grains especially wheat rye barley and others
but gluten in the digestive system turns into
gliadin and the protein gliadin looks very very
similar if not certain parts of it identical
to something in your thyroid which is an enzyme
called transglutaminase so if you have antibodies
that are attacking this protein in wheat anytime
you consume grains these antibodies are going to
not just attack that protein it's going to
attack the thyroid as well simply because of
this molecular mimicry situation and there's a
lot of other autoimmune conditions that have a
similar type principle where you have this
mimicry of either a virus or a food that mimics
a body tissue but in the case of the
thyroid whether you have a hyper or hypo
you definitely need to remove gluten from the diet
100% because every time you consume it your body's
going to look at that as a foreign invader
and it's going to actually attack that with
its antibodies as well as certain parts of your
thyroid creating this inflammatory state all right
there are five things that i'm going to recommend
number one you have to be completely gluten free
number two you want to get on keto the healthy
version of keto and intermittent fasting why
because it's going to lower your inflammation
next thing you want to take is selenium
selenium is essential for autoimmune conditions
especially with the thyroid whether you have a
hyper or a hypothyroid condition the big thing you
need to be aware of with a hyper thyroid condition
graves is that you want to avoid taking iodine
because your thyroid is already producing too
many thyroid hormones and those thyroid hormones
are made from iodine the other thing you want
to avoid is bile salts because bile salts will
increase the conversion from the inactive form
t4 to the active form t3 but if you have a hypo
thyroid condition you definitely want to take
purified bowel salts and that would be oxbile or
any of the bile supplements that are out there
so selenium is good for hyper and hypo next thing
you want to do is take vitamin d3 minimally 10,000
ius why because vitamin d can help you with
your inflammation it's one of the best natural
anti-inflammatory vitamins out there and the
last thing to take is probiotics simply because
most autoimmune conditions start in the gut
because you want to start building up that weak
link in your gut alright thanks for watching hey
before you go if you're benefiting from any of my
content i would love to hear about your success
story please share it in the link down below